la mission d'information sur le fond
mariage disposant des prérogatives de
commission d'enquête a donc rendu son
rapport ce mardi 2 mois après sa
constitution le 3 mai dernier
elle a entendu l'ensemble des acteurs
responsables tant au niveau
administratif que politique de la
création et de la mise en valeur de ce
fond
et travailler comme la commission des
finances en a l'habitude à partir de
données et de documents qui lui ont été
transmis à sa demande
les travaux ont été menés avec la pleine
collaboration de l'administration et de
l'actuel secrétaire d'État madame Sonia
baquet
nous avons également envoyé en
questionnaire à l'ensemble des 17
associations lauréate du fond Marianne
qui nous ont toutes répondu
en mai dernier
vous le savez des révélations sont
parues dans la presse sur des soupçons
de mauvaises gestion du fonds Marianne
après avoir effectué des premières
demandes d'information à ma qualité de
président de la commission des finances
et au regard des interrogations
soulevées par les éléments qui m’étaient
transmis j'ai proposé à la commission
des finances de constituer une mission
d'information ce qu'elle a décidé à
l'unanimité en désignant comme
rapporteur Monsieur Jean-François Husson
par ailleurs rapporteur général de la
commission
un autre demande cette mission c'est
ensuite vu conférer les pouvoirs de
commission d'enquête par un vote du
Sénat
je ne reviendrai pas sur les
circonstances particulièrement
dramatiques qui ont conduit à
l'instauration de ce fond vous les
connaissez tous
par ailleurs certains aspects du dossier
font l'objet de poursuite judiciaire y
a-t-il eu favoritisme voire détournement
de fonds publics au profit d'acteurs qui
n'ont effectué aucun travail des
contenus politiques ont-ils interférés
avec la campagne présidentielle si l'on
peut s'être fait une idée à titre
personnel sur le sujet il ne nous
revient pas de trancher ces questions
nos travaux permettent avant tout
l'établir une chronologie précise et
d'éclairer des faits tout en exerçant un
contrôle rigoureux de l'usage des fonds
publics comme nous avons l'habitude de
le faire dans le cadre de notre contrôle
de l'action gouvernementale
le rapport de Jean-François Husson dont
nous vous présentons les résultats
a été examiné par la commission des
finances mardi qu'il a voté à
l'unanimité à l'exception de quelques
rares abstention
il est le fruit d'un travail que nous
avons mené ou l'avez vu conjointement et
je dois le dire en toute confiance
alors je le confirme effectivement on
est sur un travail qui a été réalisé de
concert avec le président rénal elle est
conclusions que nous vous rendons sont
le fruit d'un travail que je
qualifierais d'une mission d'intérêt
général et de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement dans le cadre le plus
abouti de d'une commission d'enquête
ceci étant dit à cet instant je n'irai
pas par quatre chemins en lisant le
rapport vous constaterez qu'à toutes les
étapes de ce projet le manque de rigueur
l'opacité et je le dis la désinvolture
on conduit au fiasco
ce constat que je fais devant vous ne
doit pas et ne nous conduit pas
à jeter l'opprobre sur la politique
publique de lutte contre le séparatisme
et la promotion des valeurs
républicaines sur les réseaux sociaux il
s'agit je le crois d'un combat essentiel
et tout à fait légitime
mais comme la rappeler le Président nous
sommes ateliers au long des auditions à
interroger les faits leur chronologie
entourant la création et la mise en
oeuvre de ce fond et le constat est sans
appel sur la dérive de ce que nous
appelons un coup politique
lors de la phase de lancement du fond
Marianne tout d'abord il y a un
sentiment qui a prévalu c'est un
sentiment d'urgence qui a pris le pas
sur toute autre considération si on
regarde le cahier des charges de l'appel
à projet a été produit en moins d'une
semaine
et le directeur de cabinet de la
ministre est intervenu pour réduire
considérablement il l'a dit les délais
pour que les porteurs de projets
déposent leurs demandes initialement
prévu sur 70 jours le cabinet n'a en
fait souhaité laisser que 20 jours soit
un délai manifestement largement
insuffisant pour construire avec le
sérieux qui convient les dossiers de
candidature et puis précisons qu'il a
également réécrit en le simplifiant à
l'extrême le cahier des charges
ensuite il y a le sujet du comité de
sélection dont nous avons relevé qu'il
est uniquement composé de membres du
secrétariat général du comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance et de la radicalisation le
sgcpdr et des membres du cabinet de la
ministre l'ensemble de des intervenants
relèvent donc de se faire administrative
très proche avec des rapports à la fois
hiérarchiques administratifs et
politiques entre les membres puisque
pour certains qui sont membres à ce
moment-là du cabinet ils étaient juste
auparavant membre du cpdr
par ailleurs plusieurs demandes qui ont
été formulées sur l'enveloppe classique
du fond interministériel de prévention
de la délinquance et la légalisation un
certain nombre ont glissé c'est le mot
qui a été utilisé vers le fond Marianne
et en fait si on retranche les montants
qui ont été arbitrés lors du comité dit
de programmation du fipdr du 13 avril
2021 sur les 2 millions et demi annoncés
par la ministre pour ce fond Marianne
seulement 1 million 400 000 euros ont
été réellement dédiés aux nouveaux
projets
c'est assurément une pratique qui n'est
pas du tout conforme à l'esprit d'un
appel à projet puisque celui-ci vise
précisément et viser présément à offrir
la possibilité à de nouveaux
intervenants de faire l'empreuves et de
voir retenu certains de leurs projets
j'en viens maintenant à la question
majeure celle de la responsabilité des
acteurs
autant le dire il nous apparaît au
présent moi-même indispensable de
clarifier le rôle de chacun le flou
parce qu'il y en a eu qui entourait les
procédures a permis finalement à
l'ensemble des responsables qu'ils
soient politiques ou administratifs
de tenter dénuder leur responsabilités
propres vous avez l'occasion de voir
combien les contradictions étaient
nombreuses entre les auditions des uns
des autres mais je veux
rappeler qu'un ministre
placé à la tête d'une administration et
responsable de l'action de celle-ci
a fortiori lorsque les frontières entre
l'action de chacun ne sont pas
clairement établies et quand le cabinet
concerné il revient au ministre
d'assurer l'entière responsabilité
politique des décisions prises
c'est la règle mais c'est surtout la
réalité des choses et si l'ancien
directeur de cabinet de la ministre a
par exemple indiqué que le cabinet à
rôle d'impulsion et de validation mais
pas d'instruction et d'exécution
vous l'avez compris et vous le savez la
réalité est en fait tout autre
dans le cadre du fond Marianne et je
pense que vous l'avez vous-même constaté
les interventions du cabinet se sont
multipliées
agissant donc sans que jamais lié à un
mandat complètement clair au nom de la
ministre délégué
il apparaît en effet il apparaît un
effet très clairement que le cabinet de
la ministre et la ministre délégué en
outrepassé leur rôle
en appuyant d'abord la candidature de
l'US ppm en amont du comité de sélection
en revenant sur l'octroi d'une
subvention de 100.000 euros à
l'association SOS Racisme alors même
qu'une décision favorable du comité de
sélection était intervenu en intégrant à
leur unique initiative une dernière
association notamment je vais revenir
sur chacun de ces points
d'abord concernant l'uspm l'octroi d'une
subvention à cette association a été
envisagée bien en amont de la création
et de l'annonce du fond Marianne
le mail de Madame Schiappa concernant
l'octroi d'une subvention de 300000
euros à l'usapm date d'ailleurs vous le
savez du 6 avril 2021 soit la veille
même de la décision de lancer le fond
Marianne et avant même donc le dépôt de
tout dossier de plus Monsieur Mohamed
cifaoui a été reçu plusieurs fois par le
cabinet de la ministre par la suite et
les membres de son cabinet ont relancé
au moins à deux reprises pour savoir si
l'administration avait bien reçu le
dossier
on peut dire que la candidature de
l'uspm a été en phase d'instruction
fortement appuyée par le cabinet
dans le cas de SOS Racisme la ministre
est intervenu pour revenir sur une
décision du comité de sélection
contrairement à ce qu'elle a pu dire
devant notre commission d'enquête il n'y
avait pas de liste complémentaire à
valider et la sélection des projets
était arrêtée dans les documents établis
après le comité de sélection du 21 mai
un mail daté du premier juin indique que
la décision d'exclure cette association
a bien été prise lors d'une réunion avec
la ministre
un autre alors que Madame Chapat nous a
indiqué que le projet de SOS Racisme
avait été écarté au motif qui ne se
déroulaient pas intégralement en ligne
le projet qui lui a été substitué ne
comportait pour sa part que des actions
de terrain il s'agit pour le moins
d'explications confuse
enfin la décision par la ministre et son
cabinet d'attribuer sans que ce loi cela
ne soit proposé par l'administration une
subvention de 20000 euros à une
association à la place de SOS Racisme
relève tout simplement du fait du prince
si la mission ne remet pas en cause le
rôle de validation évidemment on dispose
un ministre celui-ci doit intervenir
dans un cadre précis l'attribution des
subventions dans le cadre du fond
Marianne a incité d'un mélange des
genres qui n'est en aucun cas acceptable
concernant l'association reconstruire le
commun
s'il y a eu des dérives de la saucisson
et le même nous considérons que
l'administration et le cabinet de la
ministre aurait dû être en mesure
d'apprécier réellement la capacité à
faire et les orientations de
l'association
le versement de but en blanc de
centaines de milliers d'euros à des
nouveaux entrants
qui n'offrent aucune garantie n'est
assurément pas une méthode à privilégier
je vous rappelle que l'association
n'avait en avril 2021 que quelques mois
d'existence et qu'elle avait déjà
bénéficié d'une subvention de 39000
euros du fipdr quelques semaines à peine
après sa constitution
j'en viens maintenant à la phase de
contrôle et de suivi de l'exécution des
projets qui
on l'a constaté a connu également
d'importantes défaillances
une des difficultés à concerner
d'ailleurs dès le départ les moyens du
contrôle du
sgpdr que nous espérons voir renforcer
rapidement
mais au-delà de cette question le
contrôle des porteurs de projets c'est
vraiment révéler lacunaire
les productions de l'USA ppm était très
faible
très faible regarde la subvention reçue
depuis le début des travaux de
l'association
précisons-le en septembre 2021 ils sont
même que le projet c'est progressivement
arrêté entre janvier et mars 2022 et que
le budget du projet était manifestement
sous-exécuté ce qui n'a pourtant pas
empêché le
SGC PDR de proposer en mars 2022 un
amenant prolongeant la durée de la
convention de plusieurs mois
et je vous le dis contrairement ce qui
nous avait été annoncé nous n'avons reçu
aucune preuve que l'USBM est renvoyé
l'avenant signé dans les délais impartis
en ce qui concerne reconstruire le
commun aucun avertissement écrit n'a été
formalisé concernant les contenus
produits par l'association et qui visait
des personnalités politiques puisque la
convention attributive de subventions ne
présente il faut le dire aucune
disposition interdisant ce type de
contenu alors pourtant que des
sacréation l'association était elle
identifiée comme étant entre guillemets
à risque sur ces sujets du fait des
liens de certains de ces membres avec le
collectif on vous voit
avant les révélations d'ailleurs par la
presse il faut le souligner aucun
contrôle ne semble avoir jamais été
réalisé pour vérifier que les contenus
produits étaient réellement en lien avec
les objectifs du fond Marianne qui sont
je le rappelle la lutte contre le
radicalisme ou le séparatisme et la
défense des principes de la République
toutefois
l'administration c'est bien évident
n'est pas la seule fautive dans les
lacunes du contrôle de des associations
les échecs du fond Marianne sont tout
autant le résultat du des
investissements
du manque d'intérêt ou du désintérêt du
pouvoir politique
dès après la sélection des projets et
Saint-Denis de responsabilité après son
lancement à l'exception d'une réunion de
décembre 2021 on ne peut distinguer
aucun signe d'une véritable implication
politique
quant à la mise en œuvre de ce fond
Marianne
or les financements qui sont en jeu ne
sont convenons le pas des crédits tout à
fait comme les autres ils avaient été
renforcés annoncé pardon à leur renfort
de médias et avait vocation à provoquer
un changement avec une politique
réellement nouvelle de contre discours
sociétal dont les enjeux politiques
avaient été annoncés comme prioritaire
mais je le dis le ce que j'appellerais
le faible suivi mais plutôt la prise de
distance par la ministre délégué
ne saurait lui permettre de renvoyer la
responsabilité voire même la faute à la
seule administration
je le dis l'abandon d'un projet de ce
projet ne permet pas de s'exonérer de
ses propres responsabilités bien sûr
toutes ces défaillances qui nous
conduisent à parler de dérives du projet
de opérations comme d'abord et même de
fiasco selon le propre mot sorti
spontanément de la bouche du président
rénal ne doivent pas pour autant nous
conduire à abandonner l'ensemble de la
politique de promotion des valeurs
républicaines je dirais surtout pas et
même au contraire plusieurs associations
ont confirmé devant notre mission
d'information l'importance de rester
discret au sujet des financements
publics pour que
n'apparaissent pas aux yeux du public
comme étant éventuellement ciglé
ministère de l'intérieur ce qui leur
fait perdre une part de la crédibilité
vis-à-vis de certains publics
finalement
nous avons le sentiment que le fond
Marianne a été conçu comme une grande
opération de communication par la
ministre
alors que la discrétion et l'efficacité
aurait certainement dû constituer les
lignes directrices majeures du fond
Marianne il aurait certainement fallu
être pleinement concentré sur cet
objectif cette belle promesse pleine
d'exigence faite aux Français
nos travaux dressent le tableau des
échecs de la politique menée en
l'occurrence par le gouvernement et nous
sommes pleinement dans notre rôle au
regard des alertes qui avaient émergé
oui certaines associations associations
subventionnées par le fond mariage et
nous le redisons on fait un travail de
fond réel et ne saurait être mis en
cause mais le label puisque c'est ainsi
que
lors d'une audition le préfet Gravel a
expliqué que c'était un label de
communication le label du fond Marianne
est attaché aujourd'hui à
devient un véritable fardeau
je dirais même un boulet attaché à
l'élégorie de la République
le fond Marianne je l'ai dit a été lancé
avec une forme de désinvolture une
désavolture qui retombe aujourd'hui sur
des personnes engagées au service de nos
valeurs
pour eux nous le disons nous regrettons
les conséquences de cette affaire
et il nous faut souhaiter quand dépit de
l'image désastreuse imprimée par le
gouvernement sur cette politique aucun
d'entre eux ne se décourage de porter le
message de défense des valeurs de la
République face aux séparatisme
en conclusion notre mission
d'information est loin d'épuiser le
sujet du fond Marianne puisque et vous
le savez
d'autres travaux sont en cours et que la
justice
poursuit ses investigations pour
déterminer les responsabilités pénales
de chacun
au-delà du constat est
finalement dans la droite ligne de des
travaux de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement qui relève du Parlement et
donc du Sénat nous avons également
arrêté 12 recommandations qui
s'adressent plus spécifiquement à
l'administration mais aussi au ministre
et alors cabinet ministériel amené à
attribuer à bercer des subventions aux
associations nos recommandations
concrètes n'attendent qu'une chose c'est
d'être mis en oeuvre en espérant que le
cpdr qui porte des publics les
politiques publiques essentielles je le
redis ne sortent pas trop affaibli de
cette affaire désormais chaque acteur
devra assumer sa part de responsabilité
dans ce dossier
par ailleurs je vous informe qu'en
pleine accord avec moi-même et la
Commission le président rénal a saisi le
parquet national financier d'un
complément d'information en application
de l'article 40 du code de procédure
pénale en lui transmettant un certain
nombre de documents obtenus dans le
cadre de notre mission
je simplement terminer en disant que
la promesse qui avait été faite
solennellement devant les Français
à la suite d'un événement tragique n'a
pas été tenu
ce qui relève pleinement de la
responsabilité politique de la ministre
nous vous remercions
merci vous êtes donc tous le rapport
ainsi que un essentiel c'est à dire un
résumé de ce rapport donc nous allons
maintenant répondre si vous le souhaitez
et si vous en avez à vos questions oui
bonjour Quentin calmer un public Sénat
j'ai deux questions si vous me le
permettez la première c'est sur les
éléments que vous avez transmis au PNF
au parc national financier est-ce que
vous pourriez être un peu plus précis
sur les les informations exactes puisque
je crois qu'il y en a trois ou quatre
que vous avez relevé donc on comprend
pendant vos auditions que la justice
donc va avoir maintenant à sa
disposition qu'est-ce que sont qu'est-ce
que c'est que ces informations et j'ai
une autre question sur Marlène Schiappa
vous dites à propos de la suppression de
la subvention à SOS Racisme et que
l'explication de la ministre et je vous
cite pour le moins confus est-ce que il
y a pas de simplement un parjure est-ce
que elle ne vous a pas menti puisqu'elle
est sous serment et qu'elle donne une
fausse explication de ce que vous
relevez vous dans votre enquête
s'il vous plaît merci concernant les les
informations pour le PNF je serai
forcément vous en doutez assez bref sur
le sujet mais il ne s'agit pas
d'un nouvel article 40 mais donc
complément à l'article 40 qui a déjà été
déposé par le cipdr en premier puis
renforcer par l'IGA et donc il s'agit
d'éléments qui sont ressortis tout
naturellement de nos auditions que vous
pouvez retrouver dans nos auditions et
des éléments qui sont comment dire
nouveau au moment où ils ont été
apportés notamment la question
concernant le contrat qui précédait le
fond Marianne entre monsieur cifaoui et
l'administration qui n'avaient peut-être
pas été porté mais c'était en dehors du
fond Marianne il faut bien le dire mais
cela aurait mérité sans doute une
information en avant c'est l'audition de
Monsieur Sifaoui qui a permis de
découvrir cela et il nous paraissait
utile de le porter à la connaissance
effectivement de la justice avec
l'ensemble des pièces qui nous ont été
transmises à ce sujet voilà pour ce
point peut-être pour le deuxième
il vous empêche qu'au cours des
auditions
dont j'ai maintenant l'habitude de dire
que à chaque audition il s'est passé
quelque chose on a eu des révélations
mais on a
constaté beaucoup de contradictions de
témoignages contradictoires d'ajustement
de reprise de
un peu de termes pour essayer de
contourner des réalités
il nous appartient pas d'être nous
l'avions dit au long de l'audition nous
ne sommes pas ici des juges
mais c'est la raison pour laquelle les
éléments qui seront transmis au parquet
national financier vont permettre là je
le souhaite nous le souhaitons à la
justice
d'effectuer son travail sereinement en
tout indépendance et de qualifier
l'effet les témoignages les affirmations
qui ont été
l'objet de des personnes qui ont été
auditionnées moi ce que je relève
s'agissant de la ministre
nous l'avons auditionné
avec méthode et patiemment pendant trois
heures
elle est l'occasion de dire qu'elle
assumait toute sa responsabilité
mais je ne l'ai jamais vu rentrer
ou proposer
à notre commission d'enquête
des éléments un peu plus tangibles
elle a beaucoup contourné elle s'est
largement défaussée sur l'administration
le cabinet elle a eu beaucoup
de pertes de mémoire
elle l'a dit elle-même il suffit de
reprendre le script des auditions
il y a certains certaines prises de
parole qui sont
consternantes de mon point de vue et
affligeante
d'autres questions bien sûr
parmi vous
bon est-ce que je peux continuer si ça
vous dérange pas désolé mais
effectivement vous avez parlé du du
contrat qui est prolongé par Christian
grabel donc le secrétaire général du
cipdr alors que à ce moment-là il y a la
démonstration que les contenus sont déjà
insuffisants par rapport à ce qui est
demandé que les sommes sont pas tout
utilisées comme on explique qu'il y a eu
ce contrat cet avenant au contrat alors
que de ce que vous vous pouvez
matériellement formuler il y a déjà une
démonstration que lui à ce ppm ne fait
pas son travail à ce moment-là
là nous sommes réellement dans l'analyse
de l'Inspection Générale
c'est-à-dire sur effectivement
fallait-il ne fallait-il pas prolonger
je crois que à l'époque l'argument qui
était fait c'est que il manquait de
temps pour pouvoir remplir leur mission
et c'est cette base qu'il y a eu un
report de quelques mois maintenant ce
sera l'igéa de dire effectivement si
c'était la bonne réponse à apporter
compte tenu des difficultés qui étaient
déjà apparues mais là on est vraiment
dans la responsabilité de
l'administration pour le coup
je pense que
c'était vous l'avez compris l'exercice
est n'était pas évident puisque il
fallait éviter de tomber dans certains
écueils entre la saisine du parquet
national financier avec la qualification
de certains faits l'inspection générale
de l'administration qui a d'ailleurs
rendu un rapport intermédiaire et je
crois que
selon nos informations
on va avoir le rapport définitif d'ici
très peu de temps il est pas impossible
d'ailleurs que ce rapport évolua par
rapport à
à certaines des affirmations ou des
bonnes feuilles qu'il contenaient de
manière intermédiaire
présentez-vous
à bien lire le rapport en fait on a un
peu l'impression que la ministre était
donc très présente au début dans une
opération de communication un petit peu
puis ensuite absente mais qu'elle a
outrepassé ses fonctions comme vous
dites en intervenant plus spécifiquement
sur certains dossiers c'est un peu ça de
savoir si elle était trop présente ou
pas assez
trop présente ou pas assez
c'est une façon étonnante de poser la
question mais on va dire deux choses la
première chose c'est que
s'il y a eu effectivement un propos
clairement mensongé de la ministre moi
je vais dire les choses comme ça il y en
a eu un face aux Français face à la
presse c'est à dire que lorsque la
ministre est interrogée sur a-t-elle une
responsabilité
attelle participé à la sélection des
associations je vous renvoie à des
articles de presse également une
émission de Public Sénat où elle était
très claire sur le sujet pour dire que
non à aucune façon elle n'avait
participé à la sélection des projets et
elle a rappelé ce qui devrait être la
règle classique c'est-à-dire les y
compris quand des dossiers arrivent
directement au ministre ce qui arrive
très régulièrement ou à son cabinet ils
doivent être transmis à l'administration
pour analyse et puis ensuite mis à la
validation du ministre et nous ne
dénions pas d'ailleurs cette faculté
qu'a le ministre qui est
responsable de l'attribution des fonds
au final de pouvoir éventuellement
modifier tel ou telle décision mais il y
a un principe c'est qu'on doit laisser
une trace écrite de la motivation
c'est tout simple vous avez un comité de
sélection qui fait une proposition
ministre c'est pas juste pour signer
c'est effectivement le ministre avec son
cabinet peut analyser ce qui sort du
comité de sélection peut avoir un avis
nuancé sur ce qui se fait et peut
éventuellement proposer une modification
c'est de sa responsabilité c'est
l'accord revient la responsabilité et
donc la responsabilité du ministre c'est
s'il modifie il explique pourquoi il
modifie et donc il doit y avoir une note
écrite ce qui s'est passé dans ce
dossier c'est qu'il y a de notes écrites
sur rien
voilà on a eu une explication pour une
seule association qui n'avait pas été
retenue c'est la seule de manière
générale on n'a pas de grille
d'évaluation vous le savez on n'a pas de
décision vous le savez et quand il y en
a une qui est une proposition du comité
de sélection il y a une modification
encore après coup
mais sans aucune note écrite pour
comment dire donner la motivation ne
fiche qu'à l'association en question de
l'acceptation ou de refus donc de ce
point de vue là si vous voulez la
présence a été trop forte
si maintenant on parle du suivi et le
rapporteur en a parlé alors là tout d'un
coup c'est lacunaire c'est non seulement
lacunaire mais c'est gentil là pour
l'instant si gentil lacunaire mais à un
moment dès l'instant et même la ministre
l'a dit dans son audition elle a dit le
rôle d'un ministre c'est d'impulser et
derrière l'administration doit faire
suivre les gens nous ne partageons pas
cette vision
du tout
tous ceux qui ont été dans le Sénat vous
savez vous avez beaucoup d'élus locaux
ou d'anciens et les locaux d'anciens
maires d'anciens présidents de
département
quand vous dites
au patron d'un exécutif
que son rôle c'est de décider et à
l'administration de faire mais il y en a
pas un qui sauterait pas sur le siège
immédiatement tellement c'est loin de la
réalité c'est à dire que la réalité
c'est on décide et on vérifie et on
contrôle voilà quel que soit les postes
il faut être en capacité d'avoir des
retours surtout lorsqu'on fait d'une
politique une politique majeure surtout
si on s'appuie sur un événement
dramatique pour faire valoir cette
politique on est encore plus responsable
de son avenir donc
si je voulais répondre à votre question
qui était un peu dual trop présent au
départ pas assez à l'arrivée
mais je pense
je vais à la fois
évidemment je partage que dit
je pense qu'il faut aller plus loin
les Français
n'admettent pas pas davantage que nous
évidemment et d'ailleurs un moment donné
Claude renan a dit mais vous ne pouvez
pas tout oublier de votre vie parce que
si je caricature à peine en tous les cas
si je m'en tiens aux déclarations faites
ici même par la ministre
elle s'est impliquée de deux manières
elle se serait impliquée selon ses dires
de deux manières en allant sur un
plateau d'une grande chaîne
d'information continue pour expliquer
qu'elle allait mener grâce à des moyens
mis en place par un fond spécial le fond
Marianne de lutte contre les discours
séparatifs l'islamisme radical
puis après elle n'existe plus elle ne
s'intéresse à rien surtout elle veut
être à distance
il y a le 20 avril l'annonce officielle
donc là je pense qu'elle passe une tête
elle fait l'annonce officielle et après
elle n'est à l'entendre jamais dans la
boucle
et excusez-moi mais
pour quelqu'un qui a exécé des
responsabilités
ministérielles pendant plus de 5 ans
c'est soit on se moque du monde
soit on assume je pense que qui est
délopé et que les explique dans le cas
d'une commission d'enquête c'est
parfaitement tendable j'ai envie de dire
ça peut mettre parfaitement honorable
mais la manière dont la ministre a passé
son temps à éviter de répondre aux
questions à ce défausser voire même
lorsque à deux reprises
poliment elle m'a expliqué ne pas
comprendre ma question
je trouve que ça ne mord pas
la personne qui était auditionné et son
témoignage et ça ne Nord pas surtout je
le redis la promesse qui a été faite un
événement dramatique
et à la mémoire de cette victime
non mais tant que vos collègues ne
souhaitent pas puisque il y a un an que
vous avez peu évoqué c'est celui de
Mohamed Sifaoui pourtant on comprend
qu'il est au cœur de la faire est-ce que
vous pouvez nous donner votre décryptage
on va le chercher c'est ce qu'il dit a
priori vous avez la démonstration que
c'est vrai et visiblement il est proche
de Christian Gravel est-ce que c'est ça
en fait c'est le fond Marianne qui ne
sélectionne en fait que deux nouvelles
associations par rapport aux acteurs qui
étaient déjà voilà en train de
travailler avec avec Michel à
l'intérieur ces deux acteurs il y en a
un des deux c'est l'association nommé
Tifaoui en fait on a voulu créer un fond
Marianne pour me mettre une deuxième
association c'est il était au cœur de
l'idée de ce contre discours qu'ils
disent ou comme ça a été dit sur la
République
nous on va pas je pense qu'on va pas
aussi loin d'abord parce qu'on n'a pas
les éléments nous vous savez on parle
des éléments que nous avons des écrits
des témoignages donc nous n'avons pas
une vision aussi simple du sujet
considérons on peut considérer que de
bonnes foi il y a eu la volonté
de la ministre et de l'administration et
du cabinet
de
modifier un petit peu les procédures et
ce qui se faisait en termes de
combat contre le séparatisme en
durcissant la position d'une certaine
façon on était avant et on reste
d'ailleurs pour beaucoup d'associations
sur des travaux de terrain avec la
volonté de parler en positif de la
République en contrepoint d'un discours
séparatiste
il y a eu de toute évidence et ça a été
précisé d'ailleurs de manière très
claire donc il y a pas d'ambiguïté par
le préfet Gravel une volonté
d'aller vers un discours où on irait
directement sur le terrain du discours
du séparatiste pour les contrées
directement sur les réseaux sociaux dans
une vision qui soit donc plus contre
discours que valorisation de la
République
à partir de là
né l'idée de l'appel d'offres avec
l'idée de voir s'il y a effectivement
peut-être des associations ça dit pas
notre avis sur le sujet mais des
associations qui seraient susceptibles
de mener de mener ce combat en ligne
et puis je pense que d'une part
le fait que cela a été redit que l'on
raccourcisse délai délais qu'on fasse un
appel d'offres avec un délai très court
fait que tout simplement on ne peut pas
dans un délai de trois semaines demandez
à des associations qui ne le font pas de
proposer un projet dans le sens voulu
par le gouvernement nous ne rentrons pas
sur en quelle raison tu tord c'est pas
notre sujet mais en tout cas le fait de
demander à des associations en trois
semaines de bâtir un projet sur des
sujets aussi compliqués et aussi fin à
toucher et bien sans surprise il y a
personne ou très peu donc on va trouver
des associations qui travaillent déjà
avec le cpdr qui vont dire et bien on va
mettre en place un petit volet sur les
réseaux sociaux on va essayer
d'accentuer notre action et puis en
parallèle effectivement on va chercher
monsieur
parce que le CI PDA travaille déjà avec
lui en termes de formation et sur ces
questions là on va le chercher et ça
c'est il le dit il a raison on va le
mobiliser pour qu'il fasse une
proposition pour répondre pour qu'il y
ait au moins une association qui est
répondre à la commande politique et dans
la réalité c'est à peu près ça il y a à
peu près une association qui répond à la
commande politique et on va même jusqu'à
valider une association qui est amenée
pour porter le projet et qui n'a rien à
voir avec la question posée mais qui
vient couvrir les actions de consultants
de Monsieur cifaoui et son travail voilà
tout simplement donc il y a bien une
alors après vous le traduisez en disant
ça a été construit je pense que dans
l'esprit c'est pas ça mais effectivement
il y a l'idée de dire on n'est pas sûr
de trouver des associations pour les
faire donc on va en construire une en
matériaux et de son côté le secrétaire
général lui a vient d'aider à la
création
d'une autre association il se dit il y
en a des acteurs qui potentiellement
pourraient s'intéresser au sujet et donc
pousse cette association elle aussi
reconstruire le commun à déposer un
dossier dans le cadre du fond Marianne
voilà et donc on se retrouve
effectivement les deux principaux
projets qui sont des projets un peu
construits à la demande de à la fois de
l'administration et
et du cabinet de la ministre pour
répondre à l'appel à projet on comprend
bien qu'il y a quelque chose qui va pas
comprend bien qu'un appel à projet c'est
fait pour ouvrir c'est pas fait pour
faire rentrer des acteurs que l'on crée
de toutes pièces voilà donc de ce point
de vue là voir même je vais ajouter
parce qu'il y a des questions qui
arrivent
par à distance il faut pas oublier que
concernant l'uspm et Monsieur Sifaoui
finalement il y a comment dirais au
départ c'était plutôt sur du des crédits
du fipdr et on fait glisser je les dis
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
subrepticement en fait du des fonds
classiques vers le fond Marianne parce
que
l'appréciation je vais appeler cabinet
ministre administration c'est un peu
difficile de savoir au final qui comment
tout ça se passe mais
c'est tellement concentré que j'ai envie
de dire c'est une responsabilité
partagée
parce que les sommes sont importantes
quand même quand initialement c'est un
million et demi d'euros pour l'US oppm
dont il faut quand même rappeler c'est
une association qui gère un bâtiment
j'ai juste avec un budget de 50000 euros
elle arrive avec un donc je crois qu'il
est Président Monsieur Karine agaran qui
dit lui-même n'avoir jamais déposé le
moindre dossier voilà donc je pense que
tous ces éléments vont servir
utilement la justice et on a bien vu
dans le cadre des auditions il y a
encore des
témoignages enfin tous les cas des
positions
contradictoires ayant d'ailleurs parfois
conduit certains à sortir un peu de
l'orgon oubliant qu'ils étaient ici dans
une commission d'enquête et non pas sur
un plateau télé bon mais je crois que
c'est important parce que
on dénonce ce que et on met les mots sur
ce qui nous paraît ne pas correspondre
au fonctionnement normal
du travail confié à des associations je
nous le redisons les montants sont
élevés et beaucoup d'associations
dans la beaucoup entendu les uns les
autres dans nos territoires sont
révulsés à la fois sur la manière la
légèreté avec laquelle tout ces dossiers
ont été suivis les versements réalisés
l'absence de contrôle globalement une
seule personne pour suivre un dossier
majeur d'une telle ampleur alors
que
ce vecteur nous paraît de voir être
regardé avec beaucoup d'attention en
tous les cas la lutte contre les
discours séparatistes c'est peut-être
une des conclusions mais hors commission
d'enquête mérite me semble-t-il
d'être mené avec une autre envergure une
autre ambition et des moyens qu'on ne
connaît pas forcément très bien
aujourd'hui ça doit aussi nous
interroger collectivement l'exécutif et
le Parlement sur ces moyens de combat au
service des valeurs de la République
Président j'ai une question comme ça je
donne aux présidents la seconde la
première je dans l'ordre de pour Radio
Classique madame tout le monde quel
conséquence politique
de recommandations
faites faisons-nous notamment concernant
les le ministère moi je pense il y en a
notamment deux c'est la 10 la
recommandation 10 et la 12 premièrement
sur le comité de programmation du fipdr
on pense qu'il faut éviter qu'il soit
par trop endogène si on veut pouvoir
bien apprécier la capacité des acteurs
notamment associatifs il vaut mieux
avoir un certain nombre de personnes ou
de personnalité
compétentes ayant des capacités
d'expertise et dans des univers un peu
différentes parce que c'est ce qui
permet d'apprécier éventuellement de
donner des orientations et puis la
recommandation douce sur l'octroi des
subventions ou on propose d'interdire
toute interférence du cabinet du
ministre dans l'instruction des dossiers
mais surtout le plus important c'est de
retracer ce que disait le président à
l'instant de manière écrite avec une
motivation les interventions du ministre
ou de son cabinet nous on pense que elle
s'explique simplement c'est plus facile
de vérifier ensuite quel est comment les
choses se sont déroulées puisqu'il vous
a pas échappé que là c'est
on nage en terre inconnue on a enfin je
dis c'est de la pour ça que je disais
c'est de la désinvolture
entre désimboltures et des intérêts
enfin on peut pas dire autre chose c'est
pour moi c'est incompréhensible
oui nous avons une question de
libération sur qui peut décider
d'éventuelles poursuites propres par
jour ça revient un peu à votre question
de tout à l'heure s'agissant de Marlène
Schiappa et celle de pnfel ou d'autres
acteurs alors je voudrais là-dessus dire
d'abord qu'on ne peut pas poser la
question
du mensonge du parjeur etc pour la seule
Marlène Schiappa bon soit on la pose
globalement soit on la pose pas sauf à
dire que comment dire la ministre serait
comment dire la cible d'une mission
d'enquête ce n'est pas le cas
non ce n'est pas voilà ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas le cas donc c'est une question
qui se pose de manière générale pour
l'ensemble des personnes auditionnées
deuxième point c'est que c'est quelque
chose de très précis en réalité on ne
peut pas faire la confusion entre des
paroles publiques qui ont été faites sur
un plateau de télévision ou à la presse
dans lesquels il est clair que les
mensonges ne fût-ce que lorsqu'on dit
effectivement qu'on a qu'on sait qu'on
n'a pas participé en rien à la sélection
bon voilà donc de l'instant où on dit ça
et au vu des commissions d'enquête il y
a pas il y a pas de doute
cette phrase était pour le moins
malheureuse voilà et il aurait mieux
valu sans doute pour la ministre partir
sur écouter j'assume ma responsabilité
nous allons regarder dans le détail ce
qui s'est passé et on verra bien je
pense que c'était beaucoup plus positif
que de dire
je ne suis concerné en rien par cette
affaire je pense que ça aurait été une
meilleure une meilleure attitude mais ça
c'est pas du parjeur c'est tout
simplement une parole publique et c'est
au
aux hommes et aux femmes qui entendent
les éléments de se faire sa propre
opinion sur sur le sujet mais on n'est
pas sur une une mesure qui concerne en
tout cas le Sénat on verra si le PNF se
saisit de quelques questions que ce soit
mais a priori c'est plutôt une question
qui relève du débat public
plutôt que d'autres choses
et donc un autre un autre point qui
n'est pas important c'est que il faut
établir en réalité le faux témoignage et
ça c'est très on est dans un aspect
juridique donc le faux témoignage il
faut l'établir alors lorsque vous avez
par exemple
deux témoignages uniquement l'homme qui
dit une chose et un votre témoignage qui
dit autre chose bah c'est pas de nature
à faire marquer un parjure parce que
lequel des deux est concerné finalement
bon donc c'est pour établir les choses
de manière juridique il faut en réalité
avoir un faisceau d'indice beaucoup plus
large avec des positions beaucoup plus
nombreuses qui permettent à ce moment-là
de dire de dire les choses de cette
façon là
d'autre part ce qu'il faut bien relever
c'est que quel type peut être les
tentatives souvent maladroites de
dissimulation des uns et des autres
quelques pu être les techniques de
contournement des questions posées ça a
été évoqué tout à l'heure pour autant la
mission au final a pu établir très
clairement les responsabilités et n'a
pas été gêné dans sa capacité à établir
les responsabilités des uns et des
autres
peut-être je vais vous donner la parole
mais peut-être puisque j'avais fait
partie j'étais président de la
commission d'enquête pour illustrer les
propos de
Claude rénale sur le coup économique et
financier de la pollution de l'air où il
y avait eu par jour
comment a été établi par jour lors des
auditions d'un certain nombre de
personnes ou de personnalité
donc on faisait évidemment
comment dirais-je
[Musique]
ont demandé le témoignage sous serment
et on demandait si aux personnes si
elles avaient des liens économiques et
financiers particulier et une personne
qui avait témoigné avait dit que n'en
avait avec personne et c'est là encore
un peu plus d'un an après
la publication d'un rapport
un journaliste de mémoire de libération
qui m'appelle en me disant voilà on a
une information est-ce que vous êtes au
courant donc je réponds bien sûr que non
mais en disant je m'en attaquais tout de
suite et c'était un vendredi soir dès le
lundi on était au travail le mardi on
informait la personne auditionnée qui
est venue le jeudi et qui a reconnu à ce
moment-là avoir un lien avoir des
contreparties il y avait quand même une
conséquence pas négligeable puisque
c'est une personne qui travaillait pour
un groupe pétrolier et par sa profession
médicale qui disait qu'il n'y avait
aucun lien entre la pollution liée
au carburant et aux émissions et des
problèmes de santé publique enfin donc
ça a été assez simple mais là dans ce
cas là c'est premièrement il fallait
d'abord que la personne témoigne
deuxièmement on a transmis
la position du président au bureau et
c'est le bureau qui après à décider de
transmettre ou non à la justice et au
final la personne était condamnée
madame je vais répondre après je le dis
juste on a une question de libération de
Monsieur van écoute et on va y répondre
juste après oui jeunesse ou France 2 à
votre avis dans ce dossier mesdames
Marlène Schiappa a-t-elle personnelle
personnellement failli à son
à sa mission
moi je vais vous répondre
de mon point de vue naturellement oui
naturellement oui parce que c'est quand
même elle qui a choisi de s'exprimer
je le redis avec une annonce alors
renfort de presse et comme elle a quand
même
exerce des responsabilités
ministérielles depuis un certain temps
ne pas dire que c'est quelqu'un qui
manquait d'expérience donc je pense que
c'était un choix assumé
et je le redis personnellement je trouve
que l'idée
était aussi noble que généreuse elle
était pleine d'exigence mais il fallait
je pense se montrer
au long ensuite du parcours par une
implication forte et je l'aurais compris
parfaitement personnel puisqu'elle avait
souhaité d'ailleurs sont le périmètre de
son ministère savait bien été dit par le
secrétaire général adjoint monsieur
Lafitte avait été quasiment taillée sur
mesure
et donc c'est là où il y a une grave
défaillance c'est pour ça que je ne peux
que regretter finalement
cet échec qui
finalement nuit
à la confiance que
nos concitoyens
perte ou devrait porter l'action
politique peut-être certains disent une
fois de plus
et je pense que dans ce cas là c'est une
fois de trop je le redis parce que si
les montants sont importants mais on va
considérer que une époque où on parle
beaucoup plus en milliards je pense que
l'exigence elle est à la fois sur le
symbole
sur le combat
et sur la mémoire de l'événement qui a
donné naissance à cette prise de parole
à laquelle elle a entendu donner la
tonalité qui convient et le fait de
cette tenue ensuite largement à distance
et quand même une véritable faute
politique est-ce que c'est un scandale
politique
on n'est pas dans une mission d'enquête
on n'aime pas les grands mots on les
utilise pas et vous avez pu voir que je
crois même d'ailleurs que des ma
première prise de parole il y a eu un
micro tendu et tout de suite la question
c'était celle-là rien je me souviens de
pas y avoir répondu et je pense que
c'est pas à nous d'y répondre en réalité
la question c'est pour nous
c'est encore une fois de pas nous poser
en juge voilà c'est la limite est fine
la marge était droite mais il faut dire
les choses faut relever ce qui nous
paraît être des fautes d'administration
nous l'avons fait l'igéa après nous l'a
fait
il y a des fautes qui relèvent peut-être
non
prenons pas partie là-dessus qui relève
du parquet national financier on verra
bien et il y a la responsabilité
politique qui d'où revient d'établir on
ne peut pas compter sur l'inspection
générale de l'administration pour
relever des fautes de nature politique
c'est pas son rôle c'est pas son rôle on
peut dire des choses mais certainement
pas relever des questions de
responsabilité politique c'est notre
rôle donc nous sommes là nous sommes pas
là après pour qualifier et nous vous
laissons le soin de le faire et de
choisir vos mots non mais vous dites
chaque acteur devra assumer ses
responsabilités dans ce dossier de
quelle manière
il y a déjà eu une manière par exemple
concernant
ce qui est arrivé ce que nous avons dit
sur la responsabilité
au niveau de l'administration ce qu'a
dit l'IGA en même temps ce qui était
plus grave pour quelqu'un de
l'administration parce que c'est
directement
comment dire la structure qui contrôle
cette activité directement il y a eu une
volonté du préfet Gravel de démissionner
bon voilà c'est une réalité
en ce qui concerne le PNF il y aura ou
pas
un jugement qui sera un jour donné pour
ce qui relève de la responsabilité
pénale et pour ce qui relève de la
responsabilité politique
en République ce sont les citoyens qui
d'une certaine façon
répondent à cette responsabilité là et
qui considère que la ministre attiré ou
pas que le gouvernement attiré ou pas
les leçons de cette question et de cette
responsabilité nous nous revient pas à
nous de nous prononcer on peut
dans l'extrême dire que à titre
personnel est placé devant les mêmes le
même sujet on ferait ceci ou cela mais
ça ne peut pas dépasser ce stade en tout
cas nous nous sommes là pour que
finalement des gens qui se sont
passionnés pour ce sujet et ce sont
passionnés pour ce sujet sans doute pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce qu'il y
avait évidemment une personnalité
particulière une ministre en vue si je
puis dire dans lequel certains comment
dire ont une appréciation extrêmement
favorable et la soutiennent et d'autres
plus réservés mais en tout cas il y a
cette personnalité
intéresse et puis d'autre part cette
question a fait ressurgir finalement
parce que comme toujours on passe d'une
actualité dramatique à une autre
une actualité chasse à l'autre et bien
cette question a fait resurgir cette
question de l'attentat qui avait subi le
professeur
d'histoire-géographie et à remis dans
les mémoires cette affaire en se disant
mais voyons
il y a eu une volonté de l'État qui
d'ailleurs sans doute a fonctionné sur
d'autres aspects
je rappelle le système Poros le
c'est-à-dire le la surveillance des
réseaux en ligne qui se fait
ce qui se fait au sein du cpdr par
l'administration
l'unité de contre discours il y a des
choses qui se font et qui sans doute
fonctionne le le parquet national
financier le parquet national pardon qui
maintenant est chargé pour une part de
la haine en ligne donc il y a eu il y a
des actions qui sont menées par le
gouvernement et qui sans doute
produisent des effets et des choses des
choses utiles en toute état de cause
voilà il y a un volet qui a
si vous voulez quand on a dit qu'il
était Mornet
monsieur je reprends une phrase de
Monsieur Sifaoui qui dit c'est Mornay
c'est d'une part parce que il est pas
pensé dans la durée il est pensé
vraiment comme un coup
on dit souvent c'est une expression
anglaise one shot c'est à dire une année
on fait alors que on sait bien que ces
actions ce sont des actions qui se
construisent sur les réseaux avec du
temps et qu'il faut du temps pour avoir
des followers ou d'avoir des gens qui
vous suivent et sur lesquels on puisse
avoir la pénétration d'un discours donc
on voit bien que ça a été mal conçu dès
le départ et que tout a été finalement
tout vient de cette volonté
d'accélération d'en parler le rapporteur
dès le départ c'est-à-dire on accélère
tout pourquoi on accélère tout mais
qu'est-ce qui oblige à aller vite rien
sinon cette volonté moi je dis souvent à
titre personnel je dis souvent cette
maladie de la politique qui est de
vouloir répondre à des événements par
des contractions immédiates
et donc voilà on fait une action
immédiate et cette action immédiate au
final ça se traduit par la mise en
danger d'un certain nombre d'association
qui travaillait très positivement sur un
discours positif de la République et qui
sont toutes cités qui sont toutes
maintenant comment dire les choses sont
ouvertes et c'est contraire à cette
esprit qu'il fallait mener pour arriver
à un résultat qui soit un résultat
utile et puis si on regarde ensuite la
fin de cette opération bah ça donne de
la République une image pas très
positive justement donc dans ces deux
sens je veux dire que c'est quelque
chose qui nous a frappé dans le côté
contre-productif de cette affaire du
fond Marianne
j'ai une question de Monsieur François
vanne coûte donc de libération quelle
est l'association qui a remplacé SOS
Racisme et qui a bénéficié de 20000
euros c'est l'association la chance pour
la diversité dans les médias
mais madame
bonjour j'ai du mal à comprendre vous
dites présidents que vous avez établi
vous avez pu établir dans cette
commission d'enquête la responsabilité
de chacun
mais de quelle responsabilité parle-t-on
vous nous parlez bien si je comprends
vous propose à l'instant de
responsabilité politique donc est-ce que
au-delà de votre travail dans la
commission et par votre travail dans la
commission il sera établi où il vous a
été établi par vous que Marlène Schiappa
a seulement et uniquement une
responsabilité politique dans cette
affaire ou est-ce que certains documents
que vous avez fait passer au parc
national financier la concerne merci
non nous sommes bien vous savez ce
rapport il a de l'intérêt pour tous
c'est à dire que lorsque une opération
un article sort dans la presse il y a
derrière toute une série c'est naturel
de questionnement très très large
beaucoup plus large que ceux auquel on a
répondu ce qui veut dire que certaines
des questionnements qui étaient derrière
cette question on trouvait aussi la
réponse par exemple dans leur pour
donner un exemple dans dans les
réactions qui ont suivi
les articles de presse il y a eu des
interrogations sur
a-t-on donné de l'argent à des
associations pour tenir des discours
politiques contre
les candidats contre le candidat Macron
ce qu'on était dans la présidentielle et
est-ce qu'on a aidé finalement à avoir à
donner à voir des discours négatifs des
autres candidats
rien dans notre rapport rien dans ce que
nous avons dans les auditions que nous
avons eu ne permet de répondre
favorablement à cette question par
exemple donc
ça veut pas dire qu'on a la réponse
totale la question n'est prudent parce
que on ne sait peut-être pas tout mais
en tout cas à ce stade nous ne
considérons pas que tel ou tel aurait
utilisé des fonds publics dans un but
volontaire de le donner à une
association pour des propos qui seraient
contre des candidats à la Présidente
nous en tenons simplement à ce stade
pour ce qui nous concerne à considérer
que une association
à utiliser en tout cas à mi des propos
en ligne négatifs pour un ensemble de
candidats d'ailleurs ou un ensemble de
personnalités ce qu'elles n'aurait pas
dû faire avec des fonds publics mais ça
c'est le PNF qui dira si on était dans
la période électorale si on y était pas
et si c'était possible de le faire voilà
donc nous ne se restons dans notre
rapport il y a aussi des éléments si
vous voulez qui réponde aussi à toute
une série de questions qui ont pu être
posées à l'occasion de ce sujet du fond
Marianne donc en ce qui nous concerne
nous avons relevé les fautes
administratives
les a relevés de son côté et les a
qualifiés de la manière la plus dure qui
soit
dire que un appel d'offres n'est ni
transparent ni équitable une fois qu'on
a dit ça c'est compliqué ça devient
compliqué pour tout le monde et pour
nous de trouver des mots plus forts que
ça
ni transparent ni équitable bon ça c'est
extrêmement rude c'est Liga donc tous
les aspects qui concernaient
l'administration vont être repris
maintenant par l'ISIa qui va traiter la
le côté administration
le côté PNF je l'ai dit sans nounou
regarde pas donc le PNF va rendre c'est
ses conclusions et nous dans ce qui nous
concerne c'est effectivement d'abord
de pointer les sujets de vérifier ce qui
s'est passé durant cette période d'y
répondre et de pointer ou non des
responsabilités politiques c'est ce que
nous faisons aujourd'hui
et pour et pour juste ajouter un petit
mot puisque
effectivement le rapport de l'IGA
pointait le fait que
la démarche en tous les cas les
démarches de l'appel à projet n'avaient
été ni transparente ni équitable je vous
invite à reprendre le propos introductif
de la ministre lorsqu'elle vient ici en
expliquant la satisfaction qui était la
sienne de pouvoir enfin parler librement
dans les premières minutes
elle prononce ces mêmes paroles en
disant que ça n'est ni transparent j'ai
pas repris le verbatim et vous le
retrouverez ni équitable je n'ai pas pu
m'empêcher de lui dire tout de suite
finalement c'est un constat c'est un
aveu où vous venez de faire
et bien c'est assez formidable de voir
la ministre répondre mais non
pas du tout écouter moi j'ai juste
répondu pour moi en français les mêmes
mots veulent dire la même chose qui soit
prononcé par l'igéa ou par la ministre
elle-même sur le même sujet
évidemment qu'il y a une responsabilité
politique que de mon point de vue en
plus elle a dans son propre intrutif
pleinement reconnu et donc je pense
qu'elle doit assumer la responsabilité
qu'elle a reconnu elle-même par les
mêmes mots que ceux employé par
l'inspection de l'hégire
on a une question de Monsieur Lambret en
visio oui est-ce que vous m'entendez
parfaitement
merci pour tout ça est-ce que première
question sans la presse vous auriez
enquêté sur ce fond je pense qu'il en
existe beaucoup d'autres ma deuxième
question l'entourage de la ministre nous
dit déjà que votre rapport est très
politique et que votre opposition au
gouvernement pèse lourd dans vos
conclusions il s'appuie pour cela sur le
rapport de l'IGA dont on vient de parler
qui disait précisément je reprends la
phrase l'ensemble des témoignages
recueillis indique que la ministre
délégué s'est effacé du processus une
fois passé le lancement officiel j'ai
l'impression que vous n'êtes pas vous ne
partagez pas ce constat de l'igéa et
enfin dernière question est-ce que vous
avez pas peur
qu'avec vos recommandations notamment la
recommandation numéro 4 ça complique
encore un peu plus la vie d'associations
de petites structures qui constatent
parfois un quart un tiers de leur budget
à ce travail administratif de contrôle
alors on va démarrer par
le premier que très simple premier sujet
qui est très simple c'est est-ce qu'on
aurait fait une enquête s'il y avait pas
eu les articles de presse la réponse est
non parce que lorsqu'on fait ce type de
contrôle c'est ce sont des contrôles
apostériori c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
d'abord que le travail ait été fait et
que ensuite on contrôle la bonne
exécution si je puis dire donc
traditionnellement on contrôle des
actions qui ont été lancées qui ont été
menées et on contrôle les résultats dans
cette affaire là on en était en phase
intermédiaire si je puis dire puisque
l'ensemble des associations n'ont pas
n'avait pas terminé leur leur contrôle
donc c'est effectivement parce qu'il y a
eu dans ce cas précis une alerte presse
et au-delà de l'alerte presse qui est
une chose il y en a souvent des alertes
presse et pour autant nous faisons pas
des missions d'enquête chaque fois que
des enquêtes presque au-delà de ça il y
a eu une émotion très forte sur le sujet
des demandes je le rappelle de mission
d'enquête qui ont été réalisés à la fois
au Sénat et à la fois à l'Assemblée
nationale et donc il ne l'a pas eu utile
d'aller rapidement sur cette sur ce
sujet pour lever les doutes et voir par
en demandant les communications des
pièces s'il y avait la réalité d'un
problème ou pas voilà donc effectivement
c'est une accélération de ce qu'est
notre système de contrôle le système de
contrôle serait intervenu éventuellement
parce que des fonds comme vous l'avez
dit il y en a énormément sur en tout cas
à la fin de du processus et non pas si
je puis dire au milieu du processus
je confirme j'ai mon même moi-même dit
vous le verrez enfin vous pourrez le
lire dans le compte rendu de des travaux
de notre commission j'ai moi-même dit
que je rendais hommage au travail
finalement de la presse puisque nous
nous serions pas saisis de ce dossier si
la presse n'avait pas
eu l'occasion de d'interpeller l'opinion
ce qui me permet de redire une fois de
plus que dans des temps difficiles ou le
système institutionnel dans son ensemble
et souvent mise en cause par l'opinion
publique je vois là de mon point de vue
un moment qu'il faut prendre avec
comment dirais-je positivement de d'un
bon fonctionnement des institutions de
la République la presse fait son travail
en toute liberté indépendance le
Parlement
peut se saisir en l'occurrence une des
deux chambres c'est saisie et je le dis
tout de suite sans parti pris
et en faisant son travail dans la sa
mission de contrôle
je trouve comment vous dire
je trouve petit et pas la hauteur les
commentaires
de l'entourage de la ministre
je crois que c'est pas au niveau du
sujet sur lequel on travaille
et je le dis sans aucun complexe sans
vouloir en tous les cas à titre
personnel me donnait un rôle une
fonction qui ne serait pas le mien et je
pense que l'affaire est trop sérieuse
pour dire c'est un combat politique
simplement on a fait notre travail
et on l'a fait plutôt de manière mesurée
en résistant
à toutes les provocations
[Musique]
je pense malheureusement les stratégies
des uns des autres il m'appartient pas
de les qualifier là mais dans les deux
cas enfin d'ailleurs dans tous les cas
puisque je l'ai dit parfois les
auditions sans être parcequement longues
nous ont permis de déceler je l'ai dit
des contradictions des incohérences de
calendrier de décision bon
et le Parlement il fait son travail avec
sérénité mais je le dis avec sérieux et
la plus grande objectivité
donc
j'invite la ministre et son entourage à
éviter de rentrer dans des polémiques
inutiles qui de plus ne servent pas la
cause de la politique enfin
vous posez deux autres questions la
ministre ce serait effacé ecoutez moi je
trouve qu'elle c'est pas vraiment pas ce
muraille l'histoire là
parce que au gré au fil des événements
comment
à mon avis les ga va vous dire le
contraire
dans son rapport définitif
voilà je sais pas du teasing mais je
pense que va dire le contraire
est-ce que il y a eu tellement de faits
que la ministre a évoqué elle-même c'est
un ça paraît ça paraît assez difficile
surtout
concernant l'association SOS Racisme
enfin sur moi j'entends dans les
recommandations on voit bien
c'est toujours difficile de trouver le
juste équilibre nous avons dit nous-même
ici des sénateurs et exercer des
responsabilités locales de
responsabilité d'exécutif local ont
rappelé qu'en général lorsque des
associations venaient solliciter un
soutien des collectivités publiques des
mairies des départements en leur
demandait un an d'existence des
justificatifs ce qui paraît le moins et
là pour au moins une on a donné des
sommes qui sont pas tout à fait neutres
sans justificatif et pour une autre avec
un petit budget des sommes assez énormes
et donc
on pense qu'il faut mettre davantage de
rigueur mais la rigueur comment
dirais-je je pense qu'il faut la mettre
avec des moyens qui sont les moyens
d'aujourd'hui
pour beaucoup d'associations il faut
certainement que le contrôle puisse être
fait de manière assez souple c'est à
dire vous avez deux ou trois éléments à
fournir quand on vous les demande et
puis si vous les fournissez il n'y a pas
de problème mais il vous a pas échappé
que pour deux associations c'était quand
même compliqué
d'avoir les éléments donc
on est bien obligé de mettre de la
rigueur parce que sinon on nous
reprocherait au reprocherait à l'état
d'être négligeant dispendieux et
finalement de faire du clientélisme ou
du copinage je pense là encore que dans
le contrôle de l'argent public auquel
nous nous sommes astres nous devons
faire en sorte de trouver des positions
équilibrées pour nous assurer que cet
argent est bien dépensé
sur
pour rester sur la même question
le rapport final de l'iode nous aurons
le texte ce soir
je rappelle que le premier rapport dit
simplement que l'igéa constate qu'il n'y
a pas de témoignage mettant en cause
Madeleine
prend pas position dis-je qu'il entend
entre temps il y a eu des auditions ici
des mêmes personnes auditionnées par
l'igéa qui n'ont pas dit la même chose
qui ont été réauditionnés par l'Isère
donc attendons le rapport final
mais je propose un entourage du ministre
de la ministre d'être prudente sur
l'utilisation de cet argument
sur la question bon c'est assez
classique
la réponse était prête avant même la
diffusion de notre rapport c'est à dire
six disent ça on dira ça s'ils disent ça
on dira ça on connaît ça voilà c'est
encore une fois une maladie des cabinets
on prépare toutes les tout ce qui peut
arriver voilà donc on a un test qui est
préparé depuis ce matin au cas où la
commission mettra en cause la ministre
très bien
je vous renvoie un article
de l'inchapad en valeur actuelle
récent
de hier
ou d'aujourd'hui
quand on a eu aujourd'hui
et dans cet article de valeur actuelle
elle se pose en victime
alors pas victime de la commission
d'enquête pas encore les victimes de
tout le reste
donc voilà c'est on continue au lieu au
lieu vous voyez c'est toujours la même
position
au lieu de tourner en positif les choses
c'est-à-dire de reconnaître un certain
de responsabilités et de réduire ses
responsabilités à ce qu'elles sont ce
que nous faisons nous-mêmes à ce
qu'elles sont
voilà il y a eu détournement financiers
vers Madeleine Schiappa nous ne le
pensons pas c'est pas à nous de le dire
mais on a en tout cas rien vu qu'il soit
de cette nature là est-ce qu'il y a eu
[Musique]
un certain nombre de points que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure concernant
l'utilisation d'une association dans un
but politique on a rien vu de cette
nature là tout ça pour être mis en
valeur par la ministre de manière
positive ce qui ressort de la mission
aussi
non pas du tout on se pose en victime
voilà victime de tout de tous tout le
monde est contre elle parfait mais pas
nous parce que c'est pas notre sujet
voilà n'est pas notre sujet notre sujet
c'est un ministre une ministre qui fait
des actions et dont certaines actions ne
nous paraissent pas correspondre à ce
qu'on pourrait attendre d'un ministre de
la République c'est ce que nous disons
très tranquillement que nous affirmons
nous avons un rapport de 100 pages et
d'une cinquantaine de pages annexes qui
le démontre
et nous en resterons là sur ce point là
mais je pense que on peut sortir de
cette affaire par le haut où on peut
sortir par l'idée de la victimisation
et sincèrement
c'est consternant de tous les points de
vue
d'autres questions
il y en a pas en ligne ah ben tout va
bien merci à vous tous